الانضمام الى المجموعة. وماذا
بعد ايها الجزائريون? بينما
على خطوة اقتصادية مهمة. وهي
استفزازية للاتحاد الاوروبي في
الوقت ذاته. انها الانضمام الى
التكتل الاقتصادي البريكس الذي
بهدوء من انشاء اقوى جيش في
المنطقة خلال عشرين عاما فقط
يتصيد الامريكان الاخطاء
للجزائر. تفتح روسيا مخازن
هذا التحالف الى الولايات
المتحدة. فهل حان وقت تقديم
الروسية جعلت الجيش الاقوى في
شمال افريقيا لتتمكن الجزائر
اسلحتها المرعبة بدون قيد او شرط
للجزائريين. قائلين لهم
تتزعمه والصين. تستغل الجزائر
لذلك دعم روسيا في طلب الانضمام
يصرح الروس قائلين. ان موسكو لا
تعترض على رغبة الجزائر في
واشنطن بعد التنازلات للجزائر ام
ان الرئيس تبون وحكومته مكتفون
الغواصة اطلق عليهما اسماء
الاوراس صفر واحد وثلاثون
الف الملقبة بالشمس الحارقة. ومع
اواخر خريف عام الفين وثمانية
بترسانته التكنولوجية الروسية
بشكل اساسي. تكتل اجتماع الكبار.
عشر حتى سبعة عشر مليار دولار.
وفق صحيفة الشرق الاوسط. الاسلحة
والهقار صفر اثنان وثلاثون.
ليتجاوز المبلغ الاجمالي للعقود
بعد ان راهنت على التحالف
العسكري مع روسيا. تقدم الجزائر
الاسود التي تنثر الرعب باعماق
وحصلت الجزائر على اثنتين من هذه
فلتختاروا ما شئتم يا هؤلاء.
فالحليف لا يترك حليفه. ليصل صدى
والتحسينات على الطائرة. وتبقى
المفاجأة القوية باحتمال وصول
لمجموعة بيريكس. وهو طموح تسعى
لبلوغه في اقرب وقت ممكن. وهنا
خلال هذه السنوات ثلاثة عشر فاصل
خمسة مليار دولار. لينتهي عام
الفين واثنين وعشرين بصفقة بيع
اسلحة بين البلدين بقيمة اثني
عشر تحركت الى الجزائر احدى اخطر
الغواصات بالعالم. غواصة الثقب
دولار. لكن الصفقة تمت دون دعاية
واسعة. وفي جو من السرية. اشترت
لكن جميع الاسلحة في كفة وانضمام
مقاتلات روسية من الجيل الخامس
بصواريخ اسكندر التي توصف
بالمرعبة. لانها ذات سرعة فائقة
المتوازن الذي تنتجه الجزائر في
الشؤون الاقليمية والدولية.
سو سبعة وخمسين في كفة اخرى.
صفقة سيتم تسليمها في عام الفين
الاحسن في العالم والقادرة على
مواجهة كل الطائرات الغربية مهما
عشر استلم الجيش الجزائري انظمة
قاذفة اللهب الثقيلة توس واحد
مستخدم نشط للاسلحة الروسية بعد
الهند. ويعتبر الجيش الجزائري هو
بتزويد الجزائر بنظام اربعمائة
المضاد للطيران والذي يعتبر
على سوق السلاح الروسي. لان
الروس لا يضعون شروطا عند بيع
ضرب اهداف في الاراضي الاوروبية
الجنوبية ولا يمكن اعتراضها
الاكثر استعدادا للقتال في
افريقيا فهو مسلح بانظمة روسية
وخمسة وعشرين. وفق التقارير بعد
اجراء المزيد من التعديلات
وقوة تدميرية هائلة. بما فيها
ضرب السفن الحربية عرض البحر او
الحياد الذي تلتزمه الجزائر في
السياسة لن يكون عسكريا ابدا.
الجزائر بنشاط المعدات العسكرية
السوفيتية ثم الروسية وهي ثاني
الجزائريين الذين اتهموا بشراء
اسلحة ضخمة من روسيا. فهي من بين
حجم التبادل التجاري بين روسيا
والجزائر ليكسر اربعة مليارات
اكبر ثلاث مشترين للاسلحة
الروسية في العالم. لكن بوتين لا
الاسلحة. والجزائر كما هو معروف
ذات حساسية كبيرة جدا حيال
وتآلفوا معها. والاسلحة الروسية
مشهورة عالميا وذات قوة وقدرة
نظام اس خمسمائة المضاد
للطائرات. الذي من شأنه ان يكمل
الدفاع الجوي للبلاد بشكل مثالي.
والقصة لا تنتهي هنا. تقوم روسيا
بسهولة. بحسب مجلة ارامكس
ستاندرات. وفي عام الفين وثمانية
دولار في العام الفين واحد
وعشرين. لتوقع الجزائر عقدا مع
على استقلال قرارها السياسي.
والسبب الثاني ان الضباط وكل
الامريكية. وفي عام الفين واربعة
عشر. موسكو تزود الجزائر سرا
روسيا لتوريد اسلحة روسية جديدة.
وفقا بصفقة بلغت سبعة مليارات
كانت قوتها بما في ذلك الرافال
الفرنسية واف خمسة وثلاثون
التدخل في شؤونها الداخلية ولا
تقبل بذلك ابدا. وهي تحافظ دائما
يغامر بادخال في مواجهة مع الغرب
بقوله ان روسيا تدعم الخط
قتالية عالية. وهنا تكمن الرغبة
الجزائرية. صفقات مرعبة. قارب
عناصر الجيش الجزائري اعتادوا
على تكنولوجيا الاسلحة الروسية
عبدالمجيد تبون للقيامة بزيارة
الى روسيا. ليقف الحليف مع حليفه
فعندما يكون الامر متعلقا
بالسلاح العسكري يقع الاختيار
ومجموعة من سبعة وعشرين عضوا
منتخبا في الكونجرس. يطالب وزير
بدأت اعادة تسليح الجيش الجزائري
من جديد. وحصلت الجزائر بموجب
الصفقة على اربعين طائرة تسعة
وعشرين. وعشرين سوخوي وستة عشر
الصديقة فقط. والرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يتحدث تفاعل
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
بفرض عقوبات على بعض المسؤولين
حلفاء منذ عقود. بدأت الحرب
الاوكرانية. الغرب يجمعون
لتأسيس العلاقات الدبلوماسية.
ودعونا الرئيس الجزائري
وترفض التصويت على قرار الامم
المتحدة. يطالب روسيا بالتوقف
طائرة ياك مائة وثلاثون المخصصة
للتدريب. وثمانية انظمة صواريخ
روسيا مع الجمهورية الجزائرية هو
من طبيعة الشراكة الاستراتيجية.
الى الجزائر بزيارة رسمية.
والروس لا يزورون غير الدول
وفي مارس من عام الفين واثنين
وعشرين. احتفلنا بالذكرى الستين
بالجزائر نتحدث وللقصة بقية.
بوتين في الجزائر. في مطلع عام
التحالفات بقيادة واشنطن. اوروبا
تبحث عن غاز بديل للغاز الروسي
حيث سبقها اعلان عن الغاء ديون
جزائرية تعود الى الاتحاد
فورا عن استخدام القوة ضد
اوكرانيا. تحرك الامريكان فورا.
لسد مجاعة الطاقة لديها. فجأة
يصل وزير الروسي سيرجي لافروف
من طراز اس ثلاثمائة. اضافة الى
اربعين دبابة حديثة وفق وكالة.
سبعة مليار دولار مقابل شراء
الجزائر لاسلحة وطائرات حربية
السوفيتي سابقا. ليلغي بوتين
ديونا جزائرية قدرها اربعة فاصل
الفين وستة. وصل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الى الجزائر. ومن
الدب الروسي. نسيت دين الماضي
لتكسب الحاضر والمستقبل. هناك
هنا كانت البداية لتجديد
العلاقات بعد فترة من الركود.
روسية بقيمة ثلاثة فاصل خمسة
مليار دولار. فيال ذكائك ايها
بيركس الذي تتزعمه روسيا والصين.
صفقات ضخمة وتاريخية بين الجزائر
اقتصادية استفزازية للاتحاد
الاوروبي باقترابها من تكتل
الجزائريون على التحالف العسكري
مع الروس. تقدمت الجزائر بخطوة
علاقة بوتين بالجزائر؟ وكيف تنظر
لها الولايات المتحدة؟ ولماذا
وروسيا. البلدان البعيدان
جغرافيا والقريبان عسكريا. هي
تصر الجزائر على تسليح جيشها
بالسلاح الروسي؟ عن علاقة بوتين
القوى الكبرى يا سادة. الدب
الروسي والمارد الجزائري. راهن
ستون عاما من العلاقات
الدبلوماسية المتينة. انه تحالف
بالتحالف مع الدب الروسي؟